obviously tonight was Michael Buble
night how did you think he did how do
you what would you rate him on a scale
of one to ten I'd give him a nine
because that's what he gave me I feel
like that is totally fair
that's what you get
uh you know I know obviously the scores
were a little bit lower this week but
still beautiful performance how are you
guys feeling after tonight feeling great
first of all I think Michael fit really
well into the ballroom it just you know
obviously his music but his Energy's
Persona really complemented uh the show
really exciting about that and uh yeah
it feels good I mean we didn't get a
perfect score like last week but it
doesn't always happen and that's fine it
gives us a chance to improve and grow
and kind of hear the feedback and get
better
uh what was it like having Jenna uh with
you guys to rehearse this week
it's always an honor I feel like to
learn from Jenna as well as Val she's so
talented and it's nice to have a woman
kind of teach you
um the different parts of always yeah
yeah
it's easier no stop he's the best but
just like you even said it in another
interview
no you're a good lady show it off you
are yeah
um it was great
this is a 10 for me guys
um you know next week is also Halloween
week I feel like that's a pretty big
night usually in Dancing with the Stars
how excited are you guys what can you
tease what can you say anything to suck
your blood
is that a hint we're vampires yeah so
you know it lends we have Argentine
tango and and within that theme it kind
of really complements one another so I'm
excited we have an amazing song like
it's gonna be fun are you excited that
the group dances back yeah Team dances
you know these are the the times when
the celebs get to really kind of build
friendships and and really get the full
experience of Dancing With the Stars
which is that experience it's not just
one dude you know yelling at her for 10
weeks tell me about it it's
collaborating with others it's it's
about you know experiencing dance with
others and tonight and the team dance is
going to provide that so I'm excited do
you guys have any other plans for
Halloween besides or are you just gonna
be rehearsing the entire time
we're going to be rehearsing most of the
time then we're going to sleep the other
time
[Laughter]
into our Dancing with the Stars plans
that's how we get to do fun stuff is we
put it in our package yeah I get to see
my wife